[Music]
i saw a story on yahoo
about jessica simpson
joking that she's on a budget what is
this all about i'm just as confused as
you can but it's a fun little piece here
jessica simpson jokes that she's on a
budget after her credit card got denied
at a taco bell you can't make this stuff
that's awkward this is there's a lot
going on here like are you surprised
that she went to taco bell there's
there's a lot of things i'm surprised
about here yeah she strikes me as a
wendy's uh fan really yeah i don't know
why okay i don't see jessica simpson in
taco bell yeah you know like what is she
getting there if you go into a taco bell
drive-through it is the most beautiful
melting pot of economics i mean there's
that right there's people in you know
sports cars wealthy folks okay it does
know this
taco bell you know does not discriminate
oh everyone loves them some late night
tacos and so does jessica simpson so
there she is the article opens jessica
simpson has some beef with taco bell
the artist 41 joked about having her
credit card declined at the popular fast
food chain while focusing her finances
on her ever-growing businesses as she
appeared this week on the reel quote i
have no working credit card simpson said
it's okay i'll pay in cash i went to
taco bell the other day and my card got
denied i'm on a budget ladies
that's a great quote right there she
added that she's draining my bank
account into growing her eponymous
billion dollar fashion brand of what she
and her mother tina regained control of
in october the multi-hyphenate even
considered borrowing against her home
for the big business move oh boy okay
that's confusing you're on a budget but
you're also going further into debt yeah
i don't know if she is on a budget but i
know this george we all got to be on a
budget when you don't have a reality tv
show very there's some confusing things
here she's got the cash to pay for taco
bell but the car is getting declined
yeah because she's got no credit be left
because she spent it all on her she's
maxed it out her company she's maxed it
that's it thank you for using see i
don't even know the right words to use
we'll get there
but it's an interesting thing when you
look at you know celebrities and
finances because a lot of people go well
you know celebrities they're making so
much money they have it easy but a lot
of people who make really good money can
still be broke
it's fascinating how that works yeah so
i applaud jessica if she truly is on a
budget i think it's great and jessica if
you're listening uh my wife loved your
biography and we encourage you to check
out every dollar ah
that's what would you say if you were
gonna coach jessica simpson because a
lot of wealthy people blow their money
they don't do well would you have taco
bell in the budget
i think so you would yeah i mean
personally you know you allow for fast
food is a part of a budget i've got to
watch my physique ken personally as you
do too yeah you know at your age it
matters even
it matters even more wow but no this is
good i like this you know we talk about
how if you're trying to get out of debt
we don't want you to see the inside of a
restaurant and so that means you're not
eating out yeah that's what i'm not
frivolous bringing it up and you're
saying it's okay well i think once
you're out of debt absolutely let's
throw you know throw it in the budget
now i don't want you eating out every
single day mostly because it's bad for
your health on top of your budget yeah
uh but a little little taco bell never
hurt anyone and plus it's the cheapest
way to buy gas these days
taco bell dollar menu there you go again
there's my dad joke for the day oh man
there's so many ways i could go with
that it's only a dollar nineteen to get
gas at taco bell dollar nineteen yeah
i'll tell you what i don't know that if
we can prove that it's good for anybody
though no but i do want all celebrities
and all normal americans to be on a
budget and to stay away from debt so
jessica don't borrow against your home
don't max out your credit cards you are
running this fashion empire use this
revenue wisely we tell people with entre
leadership to run their businesses
completely debt-free yeah and people say
you can't do that ken but we meet them
every single year our entree leadership
events and they're amazing business
owners small business owners who are
running their businesses completely
debt-free using cash love to see it very
interesting stuff there you go would
have loved to see what that order was
i'm just glad yahoo's still around
it's amazing when you said that it was
like nostalgic